[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis bekommen wir schauen heute
ausführlich auf den Krieg in der Ukraine
und seine Folgen
Putins Truppen nähern sich Kiew die
Ukrainer versuchen die Stadt zu
verteidigen es gibt viele Opfer
sie haben Angst um ihr Leben und das
ihrer Kinder immer mehr Menschen fliehen
aus der Ukraine gen Westen
und kann die Bundeswehr Deutschland
schützen die Debatte um Aufgabe und
Ausrüstung der Truppe nimmt Vater auf
[Musik]
in der Ukraine liefern sich die
ukrainische und die russische Armee
schwere Gefechte russlands Präsident
Putin ruft dabei zum Sturz des
ukrainischen Präsidenten silenski auf
die EU versucht den Druck auf Putin zu
erhöhen erstmals mit direkten Sanktionen
gegen ihn darauf blicken wir gleich erst
einmal schauen wir ins Kriegsgebiet auf
die Orte in denen die Russen die
Kontrolle übernommen haben
die russischen Truppen Rücken von
mehreren Seiten vor im Süden von der
Krim aus machen sie Geländegewinne im
Osten haben sie kleine Gebiete jenseits
der Separatisten Gebiete erobert im
Nordosten Rücken russische Panzer wie
auch vom Belarus Richtung Kiew vor rund
um die Hauptstadt wird gekämpft Volker
Duczek und Julia Schröter berichten
um 4 Uhr war ihre Nacht zu Ende Oxana
golenko schmeißt das zertrümmerte
Fenster in den Innenhof rund 300
Menschen wohnen in diesem Kiefer
Wohnblock die meisten Wohnungen sind
nach dem Bombenanschlag zerstört die
Bewohner geflohen
plötzlich gab es eine Explosion und ich
wurde drei Meter in den Flur
geschleudert
glas splitterte und ich hörte Geräusche
auf der Straße ich hatte Angst und Koch
über den Boden
die Bilder sind der Beweis dass auch
Zivilisten zu den Opfern gehören auch
wenn die russische Regierung etwas
anderes behauptet es seien nur 118
Militärstandorte zerstört behauptet
Moskau
dieses Video zeigt wie ein
abgeschossenes Flugzeug ein Hochhaus in
Brand setzt die Ukrainer sagen es seien
russischer Jet gewesen die Russen
widersprechen
ukrainische Soldaten mit
Maschinengewehren hassten durch Kiew sie
wissen putin will den schnellen Fall der
Hauptstadt Ukraine ist Präsident
selenski fordert von der NATO und den
USA ein schnelleres handeln
heute morgen sind wir allein und müssen
unser Land verteidigen so wie gestern
die mächtigsten Staaten der Welt schauen
von weitem zu und haben ihre Sanktionen
Russland überzeugt wenn wir in den
Himmel schauen sehen wir das reicht
einfach nicht
im Süden des Landes eine russische
panzerkolonne wesentliche Gegenwehr gibt
es offenbar nicht Putins Armee rückt
weiter vor während sein Außenminister
mit Vertretern der Separatisten
Hochburgen spricht
Seitenhiebe gegen ukraines Präsident
Russland wollen nicht dass die Ukraine
von Neonazis regiert werde zu Gesprächen
sei Moskau gleichwohl bereit sobald die
ukrainische Armee die Kampfhandlungen
einstellen
der Krieg ist bereits am ersten Tag auch
ein Propagandakrieg die stellvertretende
ukrainische Verteidigungsministerin
erklärt auf ihrer Facebook-Seite die
russischen Streitkräfte hätten 2800
Soldaten 80 Panzer und zehn Flugzeuge
verloren Moskau widerspricht dieser
Meldung
für hunderte war es die erste Nacht in
der Kiefer U-Bahn-Station mit der ganzen
Familie viele Menschen haben Angst vor
den Raketen
wir waren nicht darauf vorbereitet zu
fliehen niemand hatte mit dem
Kriegsbeginn gerechnet und dass sie
direkt Kiew angreifen würden
man wusste in der Panik gar nicht wie
man sich verhalten soll
wo genau die Fronten verlaufen ist
schwer zu sagen in Tschernobyl sollen
angeblich russische Fallschirmjäger den
ehemaligen Atomreaktor bewachen sagen
die Russen die Ukrainer sagen nichts
die Nachrichtenlage in Kiew auch am
frühen Abend unübersichtlich keiner weiß
wie weit die russischen Truppen schon
vorgedrungen sind viele Menschen wollen
einfach nur weg egal wohin
in der Ukraine ist für uns Katrin
Eigendorf und zwar im Südwesten des
Landes in der Stadt Venezia rund 200 km
Luftlinie von Kiew entfernt ist das
Katrin Eigendorf was hören Sie über die
aktuelle Lage in Kiew
es scheint so zu sein dass die
ukrainische Armee wirklich entschlossen
ist sich mit den Russen einen
Häuserkampf zu liefern wenn die nun
wirklich die Hauptstadt einnehmen
Präsident selensky hat vor einer Stunde
nochmal seine Regierung um sich
versammelt und mit einem selbstgedrehten
Handyvideo an das Volk appelliert
Widerstand zu leisten
das war noch mal eine sehr
eindrucksvolle und emotionale Rede in
der er klar machen wollte sie werden
nicht aufgeben und wenn die Russen
wirklich das machen wollen was ihr Ziel
ist nämlich die Regierung abzusetzen und
eine Marionettenregierung zu
installieren werden sie das nur machen
können Sie wenn Sie mit Bodentruppen in
die Stadt gehen und das würde natürlich
auch vor allem sehr sehr viele zivile
Opfer bedeuten es gibt ja auch Berichte
dass die russischen Truppen wirklich
gezielt nach Präsident selenski suchen
ja es sind nicht nur die russischen
Truppen sondern es gibt so ein
sogenannte undercover Agenten die schon
in Kiew sind die wohl planen den
Präsidenten entweder festzunehmen oder
man sagt sogar auch zu töten selensky
ist für Putin das Ziel Nummer eins denn
der ukrainische Präsident steht ja für
all das was Putin verhindern will
nämlich für eine West Orientierung der
Ukraine er will eine Integration in die
Nato und hat sich immer sehr deutlich
von der doch sehr aggressiven Politik
Russlands gegen das
Selbstbestimmungsrecht der Ukraine
gewährt deswegen ist er sicherlich für
die Russen für Putin Ziel Nummer eins
danke Katrin Eigendorf in der Ukraine
gehen wir direkt nach Russland politisch
sendet Moskau ja unterschiedliche
Signale auf der einen Seite erklärte
sich präsent Putin bereit auf höchster
Ebene mit der Ukraine zu sprechen das
berichtete das chinesische
Staatsfernsehen nach einem Telefonat
Putins mit China Staatschef
chichangelsprecher sagte man sei sehr
zufriedensverhandlungen andererseits
aber forderte Putin die Armee der
Ukraine zu einer Revolte auf im
Fernsehen bezeichnete er die Mitglieder
der ukrainischen Regierung als
Drogenabhängige Neonazis und Terroristen
fragen wir nach in Moskau bei phoe Bega
was ist denn von diesem
Verhandlungsangebot Russlands an die
Ukraine zu halten
ja dafür muss man sich eben Anschauen
von welchen Tönen dieses angebliche
Angebot heute begleitet wurde am Abend
hat sich das russische Außenministerium
noch mal zu Wort gemeldet und hat
erklärt das Verhandlungen überhaupt erst
dann zur Erfolg führen könnten wenn die
Ukraine ich zitiere entnazifiziert und
dem militarisiert sei und da ist eben
sind eben die Worte des kremlschefs
selber der die Regierung in Kiew
beschimpft hat als Drogenabhängige Bande
das scheint mir nicht die richtige
Grundlage für ernsthafte Verhandlungen
zu sein ich denke es geht da aus
Moskauer Sicht eher darum in dieser
ganzen Kriegsrhetorik in dieser in
diesen Feindseligkeiten ab und zu mal
etwas aufscheiden zu lassen was es der
Moskau dann möglich macht vor diese
Militäroffensive weiterhin als
Friedensmission zu bezeichnen denn das
ist ja die propagandaerzählung die
Präsident Putin verbreitet wissen möchte
das heißt das auch Putin ruft die
ukrainische Armee auf die Macht zu
übernehmen was steckt dahinter was ist
da die strategieputins
auch daraus spricht die Logik und die
Rechtfertigung von Wladimir Putin für
diesen Krieg wenn er jetzt die
ukrainische Armee aufruft sich gegen die
eigene Regierung zu stellen dann
untermauert das seine Behauptung dass in
Kiew eben ein Nazi-Regime an der Macht
sei dass das ukrainische Volk angeblich
unterdrücken würde er tut so als sei die
ukrainische Regierung nicht demokratisch
gewählt das ist sie aber und er hat
heute auch gesagt dass es die Ukrainer
den Russen näher bringen würde wenn sie
gegen die eigene Regierung Aufbegehren
würden auch da schwingt also wieder die
Haltung des russischen Präsidenten mit
dass es sich bei der Ukraine um
russisches Einflussgebiet handelt und
nicht etwa um ein eigenständiges Land
das seinen eigenen Weg losgelöst von
Moskau verfolgen möchte Dankeschön für
Bega in Moskau
bei den Menschen der Ukraine herrscht
derweil große Angst viele versuchen zu
fliehen mittlerweile sind es
zehntausende ihr Ziel die rettenden
grenzen der direkten Nachbarländer
Ungarn Slowakei und Rumänien dort wurden
bereits 11.000 Flüchtlinge gezählt
Zuflucht suchen die Menschen auch in der
Republik Moldau und in Polen Patricia
Schäfer berichtet
sie kommen mit dem Nötigsten was man
eben tragen kann nur weg aus der Ukraine
zum Beispiel nach Polen über den
Grenzort medica die letzten 15 Kilometer
ging diese Mutter mit ihren drei Kindern
zu Fuß
wir sind hierher gekommen weil wir vor
dem Krieg flüchten ich rette mein Leben
und das meiner Kinder
Halina ist man Ivan hat sie bis kurz vor
die Grenze gefahren aber kann nicht
mitkommen viele Familien werden an der
Grenze getrennt weil Männer im
wehrfähigen Alter die Ukraine nicht mehr
verlassen dürfen
mein Mann muss so Militär aber will oder
nicht
ein Stück weiter südlich an der Grenze
zur Slowakei wer Glück hat wird von
Freunden und Familie abgeholt diese
Ukrainerin wartet hier auf ihre
Schwester die jeden Moment ankommen soll
wir haben Angst aber wir versuchen die
Ruhe zu bewahren und etwas zu tun für
unsere Familien
aber family auch über die Grenze zu
Ungarn fliehen die Menschen aus der
Ukraine noch wird hier nicht gekämpft
aber die Angst vor dem Krieg vertreibt
sie
mussten alles zurücklassen unser ganzes
Lebenswerk es ist schrecklich
zurück in Polen am grenznahen Bahnhof
von premisil wartet eine Frau aus Kiew
wo heute schon russische Panzer gesehen
wurden
Dirk Meister ich habe meinen Sohn
gepackt und bin weg egal wohin nur nicht
in der Ukraine bleiben das ist zu
gefährlich
[Musik]
kilometerlange Staus heute Abend an der
ukrainischen Grenze zu Polen die
Menschen wollen nur noch raus sichern
Sicherheit bringen
und dann schalten wir jetzt noch mal hin
an die polnisch-ukrainische Grenze an
den Ort chemische wir haben eben schon
im Beitrag gesehen dort steht unsere
Korrespondentin Natalie Steger an einem
wichtigen Grenzbahnhof in der Region
Natalie wie groß ist die Fluchtbewegung
bei ihm über die Grenze nach Polen
die Fluchtbewegung ist immer noch immens
viel viel höher als noch gestern man
wartet hier gerade auch zwei große Züge
aus Kiew die sehr sehr stark viele
Stunden verspätet sind es steht immer
wieder die Frage im Raum kommen den Züge
aus der Ukraine noch raus aber im Moment
sieht es noch danach aus wir haben auch
gedreht in dem Grenzort in dem die
Menschen wie sie es im Beitrag gesehen
haben zum Fuß über die Grenze kommen
sehr viel Verzweiflung haben dort hätten
wir gerne live berichtet ist allerdings
nicht möglich weil verständlicherweise
immer wieder das Netz zusammenbricht die
Hilfsbereitschaft ist überall im Land
groß muss man sagen wir haben gesehen
auch an der Grenze haben wir gesprochen
mit den polnischen Zöllnern die sagen
auf der anderen Seite auf der
ukrainischen da sind kilometerlangen
Staus die Menschen müssen oft
stundenlang warten aber das liegt nicht
an den polnischen Grenzbeamten den die
lassen die Leute seit heute seit heute
morgen auch wirklich mit Papieren die
nicht mehr gültig sind raus aber es sind
einfach zu viele Menschen die im Moment
hier nach Polen strömen danke Nathalie
Steeger für die Eindrücke von der
polnisch-ukrainischen Grenze
und ukrainische Flüchtlinge werden wohl
auch nach Deutschland kommen um sich
darauf vorzubereiten spricht
Bundeskanzler Scholz zur Stunde mit den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten der Länder
wenn sie den Menschen im Kriegsgebiet
helfen wollen das Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe leistet humanitäre
Hilfe unter anderem mit Notunterkünften
und Lebensmitteln für Binnenflüchtlinge
die ihr Zuhause verloren haben Stichwort
ZDF Nothilfe Ukraine IBAN
de65-100
400-600-100 400 600 alle Infos auch
unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im zdf-text auf
Seite 890
für seine Angriffskrieg soll Putin einen
hohen Preis zahlen so die Europäische
Union um diesen Preis weiter zu erhöhen
kündigt die EU daher nun Sanktionen
gegen den russischen Präsidenten
persönlich so wie gegen seinen
Außenminister love an zum dritten Mal
schon in dieser Woche trafen sich die
eu-außenministerinnen und Minister zu
einer Sondersitzung aus Brüssel
berichtet annigelinek
es war der wohl emotionalste Moment
dieses EU-Gipfels der ukrainische
Präsident selenski schaltete sich
gestern Abend aus Kiew in die
Gipfelrunde er bittet um scharfe
Sanktionen und weitere Unterstützung
er hat uns gesagt dass er nicht wisse ob
er noch einmal mit uns sprechen könne
das war hart wir müssen uns im Klaren
sein wie ernst die Lage in der Ukraine
ist am Mittag dann kontert Europa die
EU-Außenminister verhängen zum ersten
Mal Strafmaßnahmen gegen den russischen
Präsidenten Wladimir Putin und seinen
Außenminister Sergej lavrov sie sind
verantwortlich dafür dass unschuldige
Menschen in der Ukraine sterben sie sind
dafür verantwortlich dass das
internationale System mit Füßen getreten
wird und das nehmen wir als Europäerin
und Europäer nicht hin
eu-vermögen von Putin und lavrov sind ab
jetzt blockiert ein Einreiseverbot nach
Europa gilt für sie jedoch nicht man
müsse ja in Zukunft vielleicht wieder
miteinander reden
das eu-sanktionspaket zielt weiter
darauf die russische Wirtschaft zu
schwächen zum Beispiel mit einem
Exportstopp für Flugtechnik zwei Drittel
der russischen Flugzeugflotte kommen aus
dem Westen fehlen die Ersatzteile
könnten sie langfristig am Boden bleiben
müssen
beim Thema Finanzen beschränkt sich die
EU auf die Listung einzelner Banken
darauf Russland vom internationalen
Zahlungssystem Swift auszuschließen
konnten sich die Minister nicht einigen
auch Deutschland bremste Swift ist eine
Art Nachrichtendienst durch den 11.000
Banken weltweit miteinander verbunden
sind ein abkoppeln von diesem
Kommunikations-
fünf Kilometer weiter östlich am
Stadtrand von Brüssel beraten die
Staats- und Regierungschefs der NATO in
einer Videokonferenz über den Krieg in
der Ukraine
die Welt wird Russland und Belarus für
seine Handlungen zur Verantwortung
ziehen Russland als den Aggressor und
Belarus als seinen Mittäter
draußen vor den Toren des
nato-hauptquartiers haben sich ein paar
Demonstranten mit ukrainischen Fahnen
versammelt auch sie fordern Putin
Einhalt zu gebieten irgendwie
und den virtuellen NATO-Gipfel hat für
uns Florian Neuhann verfolgt Florian auf
welche Jahr Strategie hat sich die
Militärallianz heute im Umgang mit
Russland geeinigt
na man bleibt erstmal bei der alten
Strategie unter dem Stichwort
Abschreckung und Verteidigung nur dass
man diese Strategie massiv ausbauen will
und das heißt man verlegt der
Generalsekretär nannte ist gerade
tausende Soldaten nach Osteuropa an die
sogenannte Ostflanke der NATO das haben
wir eine letzten Wochen bereits viele
Mitgliedstaaten der NATO getan und
allein gestern und heute kamen
zahlreiche dazu nur ein paar Beispiele
Dänemark etwa will 20 Kampfjets der NATO
zur Verfügung stellen Italien da sprach
der Premierminister Draghi gerade von
3.400 Soldaten die man den NATO
bereitstellt und auch die sonst eher
zurückhaltende Bundesregierung will ihr
Engagement offenbar verstärken man denkt
nach über die Stationierung von
Flugabwehrraketen patriotsystemen in
Osteuropa wichtig es geht dabei nicht um
einen Eingreifen der NATO in der Ukraine
das ist ausgeschlossen es geht um ein
Signal in zwei Richtungen nach innen zu
den östlichen Mitgliedstaaten der
Allianz und nach außen ein Stoppsignal
an Wladimir Putin die NATO ist bereit
ihr Gebiet zu verteidigen
danke für diese Einordnung Florian
neuhahn
die Nato will also weitere Soldaten und
Soldatinnen an die östliche Grenze des
Bündnisses schicken auch
Bundeswehrsoldaten und deutsche
Waffensysteme in Deutschland ist dabei
eine Diskussion in Brand über die
Einsatzfähigkeit der deutschen Armee sie
sei nicht ausreichend ausgestattet so
die Kritik aus der Politik werden daher
die Forderungen immer lauter nach mehr
Geld für die Bundeswehr Christian
hübscher über die Diskussion
schon fast 1000 deutsche Soldaten halten
sich in Litauen für den Ernstfall bereit
sie würden aktiv sollte Putin auch ein
NATO-Mitglied angreifen Bundespräsident
Steinmeier versichert heute Deutschland
wird seinen Teil dazu beitragen um Putin
von Gewalt gegen unsere Partner im
Bündnis
abzuschrecken und abzuhalten doch an der
Wehrhaftigkeit der deutschen Armee gibt
es starke Zweifel seit ausgerechnet der
heeresinspektor sagte die Bundeswehr
steht mehr oder weniger blank da auch
ein ehemaliger naturgeneral lässt ihm
heute journal aufhorchen das tatsächlich
die Bundeswehr dieses Land Deutschland
verteidigen muss wäre sie dazu in der
Lage aktuell nein die Krise beleuchtet
ein altes Problem es fehlt ein Personal
es fehlt ein Ausrüstung es fehlt sogar
an winterfester Kleidung für die
Soldaten auch die werbeauftragte mahnt
eine bessere kaltstartfähigkeit der
Bundeswehr an wir haben gesehen wie
flott die 250 verstärkungskr nach
Litauen verlegt werden müssen jetzt wird
das airpolicing verstärkt in Rumänien
von drei auf sechs euro-fighter
aufgestockt und auch verlängert dass
zeigt dass wir unter Umständen sehr
schnell handeln müssen
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
fordert eine Erhöhung des wehretats wenn
die Bundeswehr verstärkt an der
nato-ostgrenze mithelfen müsse die
Ampelkoalition war eigentlich dagegen
jetzt wird klar Putins Angriff ändert
alles das ist etwas was so nicht
weitergehen kann von daher ist das jetzt
nicht nur eine Debatte sondern das ist
sehr konkret wir werden in den nächsten
Jahren oder jetzt damit auch beginnen
die Bundeswehr zukunftsfähig zu machen
um die Bundeswehr
vollverteidigungsbereit zu machen
brauche es eine langfristige
Strategieänderung so Experten wenn wir
nur mehr Geld geben wird die Bundeswehr
nicht effektiver werden sondern das
ganze System muss im Prinzip umgestaltet
werden die Bundeswehr ist nicht in der
Lage quick and dirty zu machen also
schnell und dreckig wenn es sein muss
dort hochzufahren und zu reagieren und
so könnte das Verteidigungsministerium
sogar mehr als die geplanten 50
Milliarden Euro für dieses Jahr bekommen
immer mehr Stimmen auch aus der
Ampelkoalition fordern also die
Bundeswehr zu stärken Theo call in
Berlin erleben wir da gerade eine
Veränderung in der deutschen
Verteidigungspolitik ja absolut es hat
ein breites Umdenken eingesetzt die
russische Invasion hat hier in Berlin zu
der bitteren Erkenntnis geführt dass die
Zeit der Friedensdividende gerade mit
einem Schlag beendet wird selbst Angela
Merkel die ja 16 Jahre lang versucht hat
den russischen Präsidenten diplomatisch
einzudämmen sie spricht heute von einer
tiefgreifenden Zäsur ich glaube wir
können davon ausgehen dass der weriter
erhöht wird denn
selbstfinanzminister Lindner der ja
eigentlich das Geld zusammenhalten muss
hat sich besorgt gezeigt dass in der
Vergangenheit bei der Bundeswehr zu viel
gespart wurde dass sie ihrem Auftrag
nicht mehr gerecht werden kann der
Grünen Parteichef nuripur hat heute
erklärt man werde in den nächsten Tagen
schon Gespräche über den
Verteidigungshaushalt führen und das
dürfte spannend werden denn dabei geht
es natürlich auch um Geld das für andere
Ziele der Ampel wie beispielsweise ja
die Energiewende dann fehlen dürfte
Dankeschön Theo call
für viele Menschen in Deutschland ist
der Krieg in der Ukraine erschüttern
nahe sie bangen um das Leben ihrer
Verwandten Freunde Geschäftspartner
sowie Thomas Schiemann
lebensmittelexporteur aus Essen die
Familie seiner Frau hat sich einen
Bunker in der ostukrainischen Stadt
harkow geflüchtet fast stündlich
schicken sie verzweifelte Nachrichten
Dominik Müller Russell berichtet dass
meine Schwester sie ist
psychotherapeutin
16 Kinder geben sind diese Bilder
eingetroffen aus einem Bunker in hakif
Ludmilla schiemanns Schwester nadja hat
sie gepostet nach Essen ins Ruhrgebiet
um zu zeigen dass es ihr und der Familie
gut gibt hier haben sie die Nacht
verbracht von hier hören Sie Explosionen
Ludmilla Schiemann übersetzt ihn Bericht
es fehle ihnen im Bunker an nichts alles
gut wir haben alles die Menschen sitzen
alle zusammen
die Schulter zur Schulter und haben
Angst versuchen wahrscheinlich sie zu
beruhigen
ruhig zu bleiben mit Kartenspielen
versuchen die alten sich abzulenken tut
mir Lea Schiemann und jemand Thomas
haben einen Lebensmittel Export sie
haben nicht nur Familie sondern auch
Mitarbeiter und enge Geschäftspartner in
der Ukraine rund um die Uhr halten Sie
jetzt Kontakt reden hören zu was los ist
die einfach sehen sie sind jetzt nicht
alleine wenn sie schon alleine sind das
aber Menschen da sind die an sie denken
um mein Gefühl ist dass das auch gut
ankommt und dass das für die Leute
wichtig ist dass wir Kontakt halten
Anruf bei Ludmilla Schwester Nadja in
rakif
die nächste Nacht sie können nichts tun
außer zuzuhören und da zu sein
fast schon minütlich gibt es neue
Meldungen zum Krieg in der Ukraine
direkt nach uns folgt dazu ein
zdf-spezial alle Entwicklungen können
Sie außerdem in unserem Live-Blog
verfolgen auf ZDF heute und in unserer
App
schauen wir jetzt auf weitere
Nachrichten des Tages und beginnen mit
Corona die bundesweite sieben Tage
Inzidenz ist da erneut ganz leicht
gesunken auf knapp
1.260 auf die noch immer hohe Zahl von
Corona Toten hat heute der
Bundesgesundheitsminister hingewiesen
täglich sterben bis zu 300 Menschen im
Zusammenhang mit covit 19 sagte
Lauterbach und warnte erneut vor zu
schnellen Lockerungen der
Schutzmaßnahmen Britta Spiekermann
alten und Pflegeheime sind nach wie vor
die gefährtesten Einrichtungen Minister
Lauterbach warnt zwar sei der
Scheitelpunkt überschritten die Welle
aber noch nicht gebrochen wir haben im
Moment mit die höchsten Todeszahlen die
wir in den letzten Monaten gehabt haben
und wir sind auch noch nicht sicher über
den Berg was die Fallzahlen angeht
besonders die alten Menschen müsse man
schützen sagt der Chef des
Robert-Koch-Instituts wir sehen zum
Beispiel das bitte Menschen über 80 die
sieben Tage Inzidenz also entgegen dem
allgemeinen Trend wieder ansteigt
und wir sehen auch das Ausbrüche in
Altenheimen wieder zunehmen am 19 März
entfällt die Rechtsgrundlage für die
corona-maßnahmen ein jetzt schnell auf
den Weg gebrachtes neues Gesetz soll
auch danach Einschränkungen möglich
machen besonders in Hotspots
gibt es keinen Grund anzunehmen dass sie
eine Lücke entstehen könnte zwischen dem
Auslaufen der jetzigen Regelungen und
der dem bestandte neuen Regeln die
Anwesenden plädieren erneut eindringlich
für die Impfung doch die Zahlen sind
rückläufig ob eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht tatsächlich kommt eine
Mehrheit gibt es bislang nicht dabei
drohe im Herbst eine neue Welle
natürlich werden wir nicht überraschend
im Herbst ein anstrengendes
infektionsgeschehens erleben und nicht
nur von Corona auch Influenza wird
wieder fröhlichen Einzug halten die
Empfehlung um sich auf den Herbst
vorzubereiten könnten sich Patientinnen
und Patienten gleichzeitig gegen Corona
und Influenza impfen lassen
darüber gesprochen wurde schon länger
nun hat der dienstälteste deutsche
Ministerpräsident offiziell seinen
Rückzug für dieses Frühjahr angekündigt
Ende Mai will sich Volker Bouffier aus
Hessen aus der Politik zurückziehen das
sagte er bei einer Klausurtagung der
Landes-CDU in Fulda ein offizieller
Vorschlag für die Nachfolge der
Staatskanzlei liegt auch schon auf dem
Tisch Boris rein der derzeitige
Landtagspräsident Profil war 12 Jahre
lang Ministerpräsident in Wiesbaden
ein ehemaliger katholischer Priester
muss wegen sexualisierter Gewalt gegen
Kinder und Jugendliche zwölf Jahren Haft
dazu hat ihn das Landgericht Köln
verurteilt die Kammer saß als erwiesen
an dass da heute 70-jährigen insgesamt
110 Fällen minderjährigen Mädchen
sexualisierte Gewalt angetan hat in
einigen Fällen ging es um Vergewaltigung
erste Vorwürfe gegen den Mann gab es
schon 2010 das Erzbistum Köln hatte sie
damals kaum verfolgt und auch nicht im
Vatikan gemeldet
eine Woche vor Beginn der Paralympics in
Peking ist heute die deutsche Mannschaft
in Frankfurt verabschiedet worden die 18
Athletinnen und Athleten und die sechs
Begleitläufer freuen sich zwar auf das
sportliche Highlight reisen aber auch
mit gemischten Gefühlen nach China dass
die Angst vor dem Coronavirus die Sorge
um die freie Meinungsäußerung und nun
auch noch eine gewisse Verunsicherung
durch den Krieg in der Ukraine es werden
also für alle äußerst herausfordernde
Spiele werden
im Sport gehen weitere Verbände auf
Distanz zu Russland die Formel 1 hat
jetzt den Großen Preis von Russland
abgesagt das Rennen war für den 25
September in Sotschi geplant zuvor hatte
bereits der Fußballverband UEFA das
Champions League Finale am 28 Mai von
Sankt Petersburg nach Paris verlegt
stell dir mal vor dass alle Völker in
Frieden leben du sagst vielleicht was
für ein Träumer aber ich bin nicht der
einzige der daran glaubt mit dieser
Botschaft machte John Lennon einst auf
den Vietnamkrieg aufmerksam heute abend
erklang das Lied imagine vor dem
Brandenburger Tor als Zeichen gegen
Krieg und Gewalt in Osteuropa
[Musik]
und blicken wir jetzt noch kurz aufs
Wetter am Wochenende kommt immer mehr
die Sonne durch wo genau das Verfahren
sie gleich von ist Intelli das heute
journal können Sie um 21 auf 45 sehen
mit Christian Sievers im Interview da
nato-generalsekretärin Stoltenberg und
hier geht's weiter mit dem zdf-spezial
zum Krieg in der Ukraine auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter das nächste hoch
läutet eine Zeit mit sehr viel
Sonnenschein ein und es geht schon
morgen los aber noch gibt es viele
Wolken mit etwas Schnee vor allem ganz
im Süden an den Alpen und in der Nacht
auch sogar noch Gewitter nach Osten und
einige Schneeschauer das wird allmählich
weniger auch an den Alpen gibt es
Schneeschauer die lassen allmählich nach
sonst klart es auf und es wird dann
glatt bei Temperaturen fast überall
unter der Null Grad Marke entsprechend
frostig wird es höchstens nach Osten hin
zwei Grad oder im Südosten bei ein Grad
sowie an der See morgen dann im
Tagesverlauf noch einige Schneeschauer
im Süden sonst kompakte Wolken in den
östlichen Landes teilen die verziehen
sich allmählich mehr und mehr setzt sich
die Sonne von Nordwesten her durch und
die Temperaturen höchste Werte am 1 Grad
mit ein Grad an den Alpen sonst höchste
Werte bis 9 teils 10 Grad
und die nächsten Tage am Sonntag noch
einige harmlose Wolken es wird dann auch
weniger und die Sonne zeigt sich immer
häufiger drei bis elf Grad ja und ab
Montag gibt es viel Sonnenschein
Dienstag nur etwas Regen im Westen ein
schönen Abend